hey stead of files welcome to another
exciting edition of instant trailer
review i'm jay s and I'm Zack and today
we are taking a look at mission
impossible 5 which now has a subtitle
rogue nation alright so let's check this
out green band lets us know that
everything here is gonna be alright okay
so where we are let's talk about 1
through 4 okay fan of the series are
absolutely in fact I've in this series I
think it's a lot stronger than the
bourne franchise and the Bond franchise
have you're just you know comparing with
other action yeah Syria I mean the
choice of directors mission impossible 5
has a new director Christopher glory who
did Jack Reacher couple years ago which
was only his second film yeah because he
did the way of the gun back in two
thousand ago and took like a 12-year
hiatus I was from directing do um yeah
it starts right off with some action a
motorcycle sequence which makes me think
of mission impossible to yeah which is
probably the weakest in the series would
you agree I would agree with it so i
don't know maybe they're trying to
redeem it was something like this i
wouldn't be surprised at all if the
movie opens but the sequence like this
yeah because it seems like a lot of
these big action movies start with some
amazing vehicular action sequence on a
windy mountain path that looks like what
this again and uh as we're gonna see
later on in the trailer if you think the
motorcycle sequence at the beginning is
nuts just wait till the very end yes
there is some stuff that absolutely blew
me away I mean look at that that's and
they're also known for a lot of
practical stunts and galleries which I
I've loved and let's just say right out
of the gate that robber else would and
shooting yes and he also did ghost
Protocol which feels beautiful
especially in imax this movie's gonna be
available in imax as well and yeah I
wonder how many stunt guys they lost
doing that sequence okay let's lean on
yeah hopefully so what the voice we hear
during this opening is very discernible
I mean it's alec baldwin and apparently
he plays the CIA director in this film
and that leads me to believe I feel like
Alec Baldwin's always the guy who enters
the film was a good guy and then double
crosses you yeah point so I wouldn't be
surprised if you did that yeah we'll see
um and so what is happening to hunt and
the sea
once he is being locked in this gas
chamber of sorts i looks like he's being
good yeah it looks like he's about to
become the Hulk or green goblin or
something let's let's hope it doesn't go
into those territories but um well
dedham veteran i really like the marble
cross like the cutting of the sequence
was pretty cool because like every time
he pounds on the glass of match the
music um and here you go a shirtless Tom
Cruise how old is he kappa no no I mean
he's gotta be an instance cocktail he's
got to be in his 50s uh yeah probably
pushy close to it okay then again I
don't think he's aged 30 years all right
and um we saw our first glimpse here of
the new I guess we can call her the hunt
girl instead the bond girl I'm Rebecca
Ferguson she wasn't Hercules might have
seen that last year um she's pretty
great in that she's been in a lot of TV
shows well we got a listen um you went
to pull hear me runners back yeah do you
remember back when Ghost Protocol came
out they were talking about sort of
handing off the series printer but I
think Cruz was so good in that movie
they decided not to so now he's kind of
kind of me like a site and we have other
returning players as well as you'll see
ya being reigns back and Hammond crews
are the only ones who have been in every
Hill and on simon Pegg's back Paula
Patton is not that that's a sham alright
so you see Simon bears our first glimpse
actually so I like the shot a lot cuz
it's a little bit like you know a
mission impossible movies much like bond
movies known for their gadgets mhm this
has more of like an analog look to it
Scott you know a little bit of a I
wonder if it'll that's what uh what
Skyfall did with the bomb Syria you know
how I took it you're likely retro so
then where are you this indicated is
real okay so i guess the plot this time
they're talking about the syndicate
which is like a rogue like anti IMF yeah
so I guess their whole sole purpose is
to eliminate all of the agents and I
mean it's quite a film it's quite a year
for spy movies actually we already got
Kingsman you had the man from uncle
coming out we have Spectre book coming
out later in the year and now this so
this is an exciting plot line
for permission series because I'm
excited to see the team just as powerful
as these guys yeah against the kind of
hunting mode only right this may very
well be our last mission there he is men
of the hour it's great to see them all
back together and i really wonder how
much how many lexus movies gonna have
like how many more entries do you think
we're going to get with some of these
guys before they need to find younger
blood yeah i mean they talk about you
know the one last mission in this one
but i don't know if this is because for
was just so successful like after three
like to it kind of hit a little bit of a
bump 3 was unbelievable for was even
better right this looks okay let's just
hope it keeps that upward trajectory um
I get through some of the crazy action
suck ass cuz this is when it gets fun
yeah okay I I love that shot that is
amazing how to pull the ebrake yeah
again else would shot this and it's
incredible how you can shrink amaz and
then go and shoot action movies like
this yeah seamlessly interchange so
crews I mean well well known you're
doing a lot of his own stunts I mean a
lot of times they take out the chords
and whatnot but he does a lot of
Impractical without green screen which
is pretty great one of my favorite shots
is coming up on the trailer which is
really oh I think it's coming up right
here isn't it yeah there's a shot Laura
Oh beautiful that's beautiful make that
your wallpaper okay so there's gonna be
a lot of motorcycle unless all of those
are just snippets from one big elongated
action since I don't know on this this
device is pretty interesting this is
like a very high tech vault of some sort
like they got eight cameras on this one
guy dragging him as he goes through and
it's great to see that she's gonna be to
kick in just as much fun as fun how do
you know we can trust her
there's another shot coming up which I
love which look at there yeah that's
incredible yeah and Tom Cruise actually
did do that he jumped through a pit to
know where no one has seen in a sense um
so yeah I know this is gonna be like one
of the moments where they're planning
how to break into someplace and thorough
through the phone it's gonna be like the
only way they can get it so of course
he's gonna do that um kind of a spoiler
there you know I mean we didn't we don't
whites okay the face that he's wearing
it's just some unknown guy but yeah now
we already know that he was bringing
back that device material series that is
incredible yeah I wonder how many BMWs
they went through ok and that's just
great that just cuts to this upside-down
shot of Renner opening up the car door
so this this movie shot all over Europe
I'm surprised that there weren't a lot
of Asian locations on the other yes
because you think that's a marketer they
keep trying to make new films appealing
so let me ask you this based on this
film on this trailer so far mm-hmm what
do you think is this gonna be better
than four I don't know I mean I think
ghost Protocol is the highlight of the
series so far that's the one who beat to
be honest I don't think it's gonna quite
top that from what we've seen here but I
think it's gonna be another solid entry
what about you I mean I had high hopes
for this trailer and I think they were 1
i'm all in and by this point i mean this
is the shot watch watch the trailer just
let it run through on your own because
that by this point the theme and hiked
in that glorious mission impossible we
saw photos from this uh yes seen in
particular online and I didn't know that
the magnitude of the shot yeah this is
pretty incredible so practical shops
yeah Cruz is actually hanging onto the
side of an airplane there's few actors
at all like let alone moving stars who
would do this but wow so Tom Cruise
he has a death wish or something got
around but it's amazing he makes great
moves he is I'd say the best movie
starts to work so yeah there you go
Mission Impossible Rose important port
of the trailer right there oh yeah it's
at fandango you can do that right now
and the movie was actually slated to
come out in december but with the
competition of like Specter and star
wars they decided to move it up which is
a good sign when a movie is like ready
to go that they can move it up six
months that's usually a good thing in my
book so I 31st so I'm there and theaters
and imax so for another exciting
addition of instant trailer review I'm
j/s and um Zack thanks for watching